Trascrizione: Clara Casazza
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Senza cooperazione, non esiste progresso:
ma in realtà, cos'è il progresso?
Secondo me,
una definizione molto bella di progresso
è costruire un futuro che sia sostenibile
e pacifico per tutti noi,
sulla Terra e oltre.
Vorrei parlare proprio di questo con voi,
partendo ovviamente, nel micro,
dalla mia esperienza personale.
Sono nata e cresciuta professionalmente
occupandomi di attività spaziali:
in particolare, come avete appena sentito,
di esplorazione umana dello spazio.
L'esplorazione umana
dello spazio, lo sapete,
è cominciata alla metà del secolo scorso
come attività di tipo competitivo,
dell'Unione Sovietica, degli americani,
quella che è la Moon Race.
Piano piano si è evoluta, ed è diventata
qualcosa di molto più bello,
io trovo molto più interessante,
e quasi esclusivamente cooperativa,
quindi una cooperazione globale.
Lo vedete in questa bella immagine,
la seconda, quella sulla destra.
Questo è l'incontro di Expedition 37 e 38,
i due equipaggi che si trovano
sulla stazione spaziale nel 2013.
Ci troviamo americani, russi,
giapponesi ed europei,
il nostro Luca Parmitano.
Non so se ci avete mai pensato,
ma da più di 20 anni non siamo più
una specie unicamente terrestre.
Infatti nel novembre dell'anno 2000,
è partita una spedizione
verso la Stazione Spaziale,
un equipaggio che poi ha dato il cambio
ad altri equipaggi, uno dopo l'altro.
Da allora, da 22 anni,
gli esseri umani vivono
sulla Stazione Spaziale.
L'immagine a destra, ancora una volta,
è la nostra ultima missione,
la più recente, il 26 aprile scorso:
Samantha Cristoforetti che è partita
con i colleghi sulla missione Minerva.
Ma perché esploriamo?
Innanzitutto, esploriamo
perché è nel nostro DNA.
Penso che sia una delle cose
che ci rende più unici,
forse che ci definisce di più
dalle altre specie viventi.
L'immagine che ho scelto
di questa fregata,
l'ho scelta forse più per me che per voi,
per ricordarmi che non esiste
soltanto l'esplorazione spaziale.
Questa è la fregata Endeavour
che nel 1915 si incagliò
nei ghiacci dell'Artico
che era andata a esplorare.
Quindi, esploriamo perché è
nel nostro DNA:
ma non solo.
Esploriamo anche perché
l'esplorazione dello spazio
è un motore di tecnologia,
di innovazione, quindi di benessere.
Anche perché l'esplorazione dello spazio
apre un mondo nuovo,
che è quello delle risorse che esistono
sugli altri pianeti e corpi celesti.
Come potete vedere in quest'immagine,
secondo me molto interessante
nonostante siano numeri,
oggi quella che chiamiamo space economy
rappresenta 350 miliardi di valore.
Pensiamo che da ora all'anno 2040
passeremo al triliardo,
quindi a 1000 miliardi.
Un'economia veramente importante,
quindi lo spazio sta diventando
un'attività essenziale,
per noi sulla terra.
Proprio perché sta diventando
così importante,
si stanno affacciando nuovi players.
In passato erano soltanto le istituzioni,
i grandi paesi, i governi: adesso, no.
In quest'immagine,
guardate la linea gialla
perché è molto interessante.
Si vede che, dall'anno 2020,
gli investimenti privati
nel settore spaziale
hanno superato quelli di tutta l'Europa,
quindi l'Agenzia Spaziale Europea,
i suoi paesi membri.
Questo è molto interessante:
cosa sta succedendo?
Grandi imprenditori visionari,
al di là di altre considerazioni,
hanno cominciato a interessarsi
e a investire nello spazio,
e a investire proprio
nell'esplorazione spaziale.
Vi faccio due esempi, che conoscete tutti:
Elon Musk con SpaceX,
e Jeff Bezos con Blue Origin,
stanno investendo le loro fortune
nelle attività spaziali.
Perché lo fanno?
Ovviamente non per filantropia,
ma lo fanno perché pensano
che nel prossimo decennio,
e lo pensiamo tutti noi addetti ai lavori,
l'esplorazione dello spazio
sarà uno dei veri grandi motori
dell'economia terrestre.
Esplorazione dello spazio cosa vuol dire?
Vuol dire, anche,
andare a cercare risorse
sugli altri pianeti,
ad esempio estrazione
mineraria sulla Luna:
e questo non è un concetto teorico.
La NASA ha già assegnato
quattro contratti a industrie private,
chiedendo loro, entro il 2024,
di fare estrazione mineraria
di regolite dalla luna.
La regolite è un aggregante
tipo il calcestruzzo,
che può servire per costruire
delle strutture sulla luna,
attraverso il 3D Printing,
che ci aiuteranno a stabilire
una base, e fare estrazione.
Detto questo, i privati
non sono, e non saranno,
gli unici a ingaggiarsi
nelle attività spaziali.
Il settore pubblico rimane
e continuerà a rimanere molto importante.
Perché?
Innanzitutto, perché i costi
e i rischi sono enormi,
e il ritorno sull'investimento
è molto lontano,
quindi i privati stentano a volersi
veramente ingaggiare in queste attività.
Ma c'è un'altra ragione,
che trovo ancora più importante.
Noi dobbiamo evitare
che l'esplorazione dello spazio,
l'utilizzo delle risorse
sui corpi celesti,
si trasformi in un nuovo Far West,
che questa nuova Space Race
diventi un nuovo Far West.
Perché?
Perché le risorse sugli altri pianeti
sono risorse di tutti,
e dobbiamo trovare un modo
per regolamentare
l'esplorazione dello spazio
e lo sfruttamento dello spazio,
attraverso dei regolamenti che i governi
devono decidere tutti insieme.
Quest'immagine è molto interessante:
è la firma, nel 1967,
di quello che si chiama
"The UN Outer Space Treaty",
il primo trattato che definì
come utilizzare le risorse
sui corpi celesti.
Colpisce, o almeno colpisce me,
che nell'immagine siano tutti uomini.
Spero che alla prossima firma
ci siano un pochino più di donne.
Detto questo, il messaggio
di tutto quello che ho detto finora
è che fondamentalmente
il nostro futuro è nello spazio;
ma non soltanto nello spazio.
Tutti i nostri astronauti,
quando tornano dalle loro missioni,
ci dicono non soltanto
quanto è fragile la terra,
e quanto è bella -
guardate questa bellissima immagine
di una missione Apollo, Earth Rising.
Ci dicono anche come la terra, in realtà,
non sia che una navicella,
un pochino come la Stazione Spaziale,
e l'equipaggio siamo noi, tutta l'umanità.
Però c'è una differenza fondamentale,
tra la Stazione Spaziale
e il Pianeta Terra.
Sulla Stazione Spaziale l'acqua,
l'ossigeno, le risorse, il propellente,
arrivano da terra;
il nostro pianeta no,
può contare soltanto su sé stesso.
Quindi è fondamentale
che noi troviamo un sistema
per vivere su questo pianeta
in un modo durabile,
in un modo sostenibile.
Questa è veramente la grande sfida
su cui si basa il nostro futuro.
Per vincere questa grande sfida
abbiamo bisogno di strumenti.
Abbiamo bisogno di misurarla,
di quantificarla,
di capire veramente qual è il problema
con dei numeri e dei dati.
Voglio farvi due esempi
che vengono dalle attività spaziali,
che sono uno di questi strumenti.
Il primo è il programma Copernicus,
forse ne avete sentito parlare,
un programma dell'Agenzia Spaziale Europea
con l'Unione Europea.
Questo programma serve
per monitorare il clima.
Ci dà delle informazioni
estremamente importanti.
Guardate quest'immagine, in alto a destra.
Quella che vedete
è la deforestazione dell'Amazzonia
nel giro di 30 anni,
dagli anni '90 al 2020,
la stessa zona dell'Amazzonia.
In alto a destra,
i fuochi dell'Australia nel 2020.
Sotto, a sinistra,
l'isola Eagle nell'Antartico,
che nel giro di un periodo brevissimo,
a causa di un'ondata di calore,
in nove giorni ha perduto
tutti quei ghiacci.
Infine, l'ultima immagine:
credo che l'ultima in fondo a destra
l'abbiate vista più volte ai telegiornali,
durante il Covid e il lockdown.
È un'immagine delle sentinelle
dei nostri satelliti di Copernicus.
Cosa ci dice?
Fa vedere l'inquinamento atmosferico,
quindi la grande differenza che esiste,
da un punto di vista di inquinamento,
quando ci sono attività industriali,
quelle che vedete sulla sinistra,
e quando queste non ci sono.
È proiettata su Cina, Europa, Italia
e in particolare sulla Pianura Padana.
Un altro programma, che questa volta
non ci dà i dati attuali,
ma è un programma che stiamo preparando,
molto bello e interessante,
si chiama Digital Twin Earth.
Proporremo questo programma ai ministri
alla fine di quest'anno.
Speriamo di farcelo approvare
e di poterlo lanciare.
Un programma, ancora una volta,
dell'Agenzia Spaziale Europea
e dell'Unione Europea.
Qual è l'idea? Vogliamo prendere i dati
che vengono dai nostri satelliti,
i dati che ci arrivano in real time,
utilizzare le informazioni storiche -
super computing,
intelligenza artificiale -
e con questo mettere insieme
un modello dinamico della Terra,
che ci permetta di cambiare le variabili.
Immaginate: aumentiamo
la temperatura in Amazzonia,
aumentiamo la temperatura dei mari,
sciogliamo i ghiacci,
per capire quali sono
gli effetti a livello globale.
Quindi un programma
che ci permetterà di prevedere -
non soltanto di misurare, ma di prevedere,
e quindi speriamo anche di prevenire.
Di fondo, cosa ci dicono i risultati
di tutte queste attività?
Fondamentalmente, ci dicono due cose.
La prima è che il problema è globale,
è un problema che nessuno di noi
può risolvere da solo.
È un problema che nessun paese,
neanche quelli più potenti e più grandi,
può risolvere da solo,
quindi [serve] la cooperazione.
In secondo luogo, questo problema
richiede una soluzione, e un cambiamento
al nostro modello di vita.
Dobbiamo veramente cambiare
il modo economico-sociale in cui viviamo.
Ma come fare per trasformare,
per cambiare questo modello?
Il discorso è molto complesso,
e non possiamo affrontarlo qui.
Peraltro io non avrei
neanche una soluzione,
non credo che ancora
abbiamo una soluzione.
Però, secondo me ci sono
tre elementi fondamentali,
che sono essenziali per riuscire
a cambiare questo modello.
Il primo è una volontà politica,
ci vuole una volontà politica
globale e di lungo termine,
che affronti questo problema
in un modo unico e serio.
In secondo luogo, scienza e tecnologia.
Abbiamo bisogno di investire
in scienza e tecnologia, e di innovare.
Infine, la cooperazione.
Con questo voglio ritornare al micro,
alla mia storia personale.
La mia intera vita professionale
si è sviluppata alla luce
della cooperazione.
Devo dire che in 30 anni
non mi ha mai deluso.
Ho un team intorno a me,
quello ristretto è di 40 persone.
Credo che siano di almeno
10 nazionalità diverse.
Sono un pochino più donne che uomini,
e sottolineo il "pochino più",
perché secondo me l'equilibrio di genere,
di orientamento sessuale,
di religione, di cultura
è fondamentale, perché è quello
che ci fa co-operare, lavorare insieme,
che ci dà una forza incredibile,
e che ci dà anche una creatività pazzesca.
Questa è l'esperienza che ho avuto
a livello personale;
ma non è soltanto una questione personale.
L'Agenzia Spaziale Europea è stata creata
proprio per far cooperare
i suoi paesi membri,
e far fare loro dei programmi
che non sarebbero stati capaci
di fare da soli.
I risultati parlano da soli,
sono dei risultati di cui
dovremmo essere tutti fieri.
Noi italiani in particolare,
perché l'Italia è un paese trainante
dell'Agenzia Spaziale Europea.
Ho qui due esempi, forse li conoscete.
Quella a sinistra è la missione del 2014,
quando siamo atterrati
sul nucleo di una cometa.
Sulla destra, quello che vedete
è un programma futuro,
che proporremo a novembre di quest'anno.
Vogliamo andare a esplorare
i giganti di ghiaccio, Urano e Nettuno,
che sono coperti da una crosta di ghiaccio
ma sappiamo che sotto
c'è del liquido, dell'acqua,
e vogliamo andare a trivellare
per scoprire se quest'acqua
contiene DNA, e quindi della vita.
Queste missioni,
e in generale tutte quelle
dell'Agenzia Spaziale Europea,
quelle presenti, passate e future,
sono tutte missioni in cooperazione.
Attenzione: non si coopera per ideologia,
perlomeno non si coopera
solo per ideologia.
Si coopera perché è l'unico modo,
non solo per mettere insieme
e condividere costi e rischi,
ma anche per trovare
le migliori tecnologie,
quelle di cui abbiamo bisogno,
quelle di punta.
Per mettere insieme i cervelli migliori.
E quindi per vincere,
al di là delle attività spaziali,
anche questa grande sfida,
questa sfida immensa che abbiamo,
che riguarda il nostro futuro.
Come dicevo, la cooperazione
per me è stata sempre il motore,
quello che ha spinto la maggioranza
delle mie scelte personali,
ed è anche uno strumento fondamentale
e indispensabile, secondo me, per la pace.
Quello che è successo il 24 di febbraio,
quando la Russia ha invaso l'Ucraina,
mi ha riempito veramente
di tristezza, di scoramento.
Questo penso che sia successo a tutti voi.
Però mi sono detta che questo
non ci deve far ricredere.
La cooperazione pacifica
è un principio indispensabile,
per il nostro futuro.
Nello spazio, nelle attività spaziali,
noi continuiamo a cooperare,
lo facciamo con grande difficoltà.
Spero che riprenderemo a farlo
a tutto campo in tutti i settori,
perché senza cooperazione
non c'è progresso.
Grazie.
(Applausi)